oui
le feu a repris dont le sudes le débat
sur les responsabilités commence
recentrage à l'auvergnate un conseiller
municipal de clermont-ferrand change de
camp l'avion européen bas de laine
la france et l'espagne font bande à part
après sa défaite parisienne bordeaux
rendons père le soir l'équipe de nantes
bonsoir
quel rapport y at il selon vous entre la
ville de berlin et le village français
d'arzacq en veulent et peu en vérité
sauf le mur évidemment symbole dans un
cas de la querelle des blocs
il est dans l'autre celui de la querelle
des voisins on n'en est pas encore au
mirador mais cela viendra peut-être le
reportage de gilles guillon de fr3
clermont ferrand voici la maison de la
famille de nains et voici celle de la
famille tessier au milieu pour les
séparer une palissade de sept mètres de
haut
depuis quatre ans et toi coulée de neige
sont venues s'installer à côté chez les
tessier les deux familles se vouent une
haine féroce à l'origine de leurs
différends une banale histoire de
limites de terrain qui s'est envenimée à
tel point qu'il ya deux ans l'été si
interrogé un mur de tôle métallique pour
ne plus voir les guenin peine perdue les
deux familles passent leur temps à se
provoquer en se jetant des pierres par
dessus le mur
au début cette version moderne des
horaces et des curiaces amuser les
habitants du voisinage qui le dimanche
venez jeter un coup d'oeil sur le mur de
la honte comme il l'appelle aujourd'hui
tout le monde trouve que les
plaisanteries les plus courtes sont les
meilleures
on aimerait bien que cela cesse
les gendarmes ont fait leurs emplettes
possibles et imaginables
les âmes un dossier qui doit faire au
moins comme cm d'épaisseur
maintenant que faire quand chaque
randonnée du fier on a ici aussi
d'intervenir auprès de la das pour
essayer de les réconcilier
pas moyen ne serait ce que pour eux pour
leurs enfants parce que vraiment c'est
c'est presque skanda leur mère leurs
enfants de créer un climat pareil des
jeunes de part et d'autre qui
s'entendraient très bien et à cause de
cette crise elle rit il se crée des
histoires
lundi soir le différend entre les
tessier et légumes ainsi régler à coups
de barre de fer match nul monsieur
tessier et madame guenin sont en arrêt
maladie
avec chacun un doigt cassé et de
multiples ecchymoses quant à monsieur
ghana et madame tessier qui était
jusqu'à présent séparés par des tôles
ils sont actuellement réunis derrière
les barreaux ils ont été placés en garde
à vue les deux couples devraient être
inculpés de coups et blessures et
dégradations volontaires
une mesure préventive dont le but est de
calmer les esprits
faute de quoi au prochain incident
sérieux la sanction sera plus lourde si
ce matin encore on croyait en avoir fini
avec les incendies du var le feu a
repris dans la journée à la fois au nord
de draguignan et dans le secteur du
tanneron cela dit ces grands incendies
ont relancé le débat sur les mesures
préventives haroun tazieff a demandé
l'ouverture d'une enquête administrative
pour connaître le sort réservé à ces
recommandations du mois d'avril par donc
concernant le débroussaillement des
massifs qui roxx a aussitôt précisé que
monsieur tazieff cette erreur car plus
de 100 hectares avaient été nettoyés
récemment le ministre de l'intérieur a
de plus annoncé que les propriétaires
auraient de nouvelles obligations
au cours de son voyage dans le gard où
il s'est incliné devant les cercueils
des pompiers victimes du feu gérard
pinson ces cinq morts je ne le digère
pas c'est ainsi karine tazieff exprimé
sa colère aujourd'hui la colère d'un
vétéran du risque qui voulait que l'on
sache qui nous avait pourtant bien
prévenu sur place ce matin pierre joxe à
replacer ce drame dans un cadre plus
conventionnel
celui de la nouvelle loi sur la forêt en
cours de discussion au parlement sur la
suppression du ministère de l'intérieur
un article nouveau l 360 tour du code
forestier prescrire à quelque chose de
nouveau dans je vais vous donner lecture
qui obligera en fait les intéressés à
respecter les consignes de début
seulement s'il n'exécute pas être à au
prescrit la commune petit pour voir
d'office après mise en demeure du
propriétaire est à charge de celui ci
cela dit ce chacun sait bien que le
débroussaillage dix mille francs
l'hectare ne sera jamais suffisamment
complet pour empêcher tous les incendies
qui plus est ce n'est pas dans des
mimosas gelé mais au dessus d'une jeune
pinède qu'un court circuit sur une ligne
moyenne tension d'erdf a déclenché
mercredi l' incendie du tanneron
l'essentiel ce soir sur la côte d'azur
et en corse
c'est sans doute de constater que les
pompiers sont partout maître de la
situation
contre exemple du massif forestier du
sud est la forêt landaise la plus grande
forêt d'europe n'a plus connu de grands
sinistres depuis 1949 où il est vrai 4
22 personnes avaient péri dans un
incendie
mais les moyens mis en place ne sont
sans doute pas étrangers à cette
situation
un reportage de dominique lang hardware
froid qui pour surveiller les 550 mille
hectares de la forêt landaise 17 tours
avec dans chacune d'elles un guetteur
dès qu'une fumée est aperçu ce guetteur
en relève l'azimuté averti aussitôt le
centre principalement de marsan si une
autre tour recoupe les informations
c'est le départ de l'unité
d'intervention
désormais le guetteur sera remplacée au
sommet de sa tour
châteauneuf par cette caméra à
infrarouge capable de détecter un feu de
5 mètres carrés à 10 km dès qu'un fait
observer un signal est envoyé à
l'ordinateur de la salle de feu à
mont-de-marsan
comme avec les guetteurs il faut que
l'information soit recoupées par la
caméra d'une tour voisine
si c'est le cas l'ordinateur qui
enregistrait toutes les caractéristiques
du feu situation évolution déclenché
l'alertent et allume systématiquement
sur la carte murale la lampe
correspondant à la zone incendiée
avantages de ce procédé il va d'abord
libérer pour d'autres tâches
les dix-sept pompiers guetteur il est
ensuite plus performant car opérationnel
24 heures sur 24 et surtout capable de
détecter un feu dans le brouillard tous
ces éléments contribuent à une
intervention plus rapide donc plus épais
il s'agit certes d'un investissement
très lourd d'autant qu'il est encore
expérimentale mais qui se révèlera vite
indispensable et rentable dans la
protection de cet immense capital que
constitue la forêt landaise
si l'élargissement de l'actuelle
majorité marquent le pas du moins à
l'échelle nationale il n'en est pas
toujours de même dans les municipalités
ainsi monsieur quillot le maire
socialiste de clermont ferrand vient il
de confier une délégation municipale à
un transfuge de l'opposition récemment
ralliée à bûches sian une expérience
purement clermontoise ou bien un banc
d'essai voilà le problème
daniels portier il y à de l'eau dans le
gaz au conseil municipal de clermont
ferrand le pc n'est pas d'accord avec le
maire socialiste roger quilliot qui
vient de redistribuer les cartes au sein
du conseil municipal après la mort d'un
conseiller émerger rien de plus naturel
si le sénateur maire n'avait décidé de
confier une délégation un ancien
responsable de l'opposition locale
gilles jean portejoie qui a quitté le
parti radical en avril pour rejoindre
l'ucr de olivier stirn le pc il voit une
dérive droitière du parti socialiste et
protège dents dans le droit fil de la
politique du parti socialiste que le nom
et du premier ministre du président de
la république essayer de compenser mais
c'est ce que la grande énergie et
finalement du parti socialiste et sa
perte de voix depuis les dernières
élections depuis 80 notamment et je
crois que c'est là une politique à
courte vue mais c'est un fait politique
que très important et en ce qui nous
concerne nous condamnons une telle
démarche
gilles jean portejoie qui n'avait rien
demandé se retrouve donc à la tête d'une
délégation importante pour clermont
ferrand celle du commerce et de
l'artisanat
il profite de la politique d'ouverture
du ps avec plus de bonheur que son ami
olivier stirn qui a du mal à se faire
accepter comme tête de liste par les
militants socialistes de la manche
quant à roger quilliot il assume
tranquillement sa décision écarte d'un
revers de main les critiques du pc
l'otan est pour même une ouverture
vers la sphère de clermont ferrand qui
jette une passerelle entre la majorité
le centre pourrait bien se reproduire au
niveau national dans les mois qui
viennent elle illustre une des
stratégies du ps l'ouverture à des
personnalités extérieures
une stratégie que le pc on l'a vu se
chargera de combattre tout va bien dans
l'opposition c'est du moins monsieur
toubon qui le dit en répondant à
monsieur gaudin qui reprochent au rpr
ses visées hégémoniques
le secrétaire général du parti de
monsieur chirac a précisé et je le cite
si monsieur godin dit que tout va bien
c'est la vérité s'il dit que tout ne va
pas bien tout va bien quand même
conclusion tout va très bien l'exemple
des quatre conseillers municipaux de
trith-saint-léger qui avait démissionné
du parti socialiste semble s'étendre à
la région de valenciennes
aujourd'hui ce sont seize conseillers
municipaux qui viennent de se mettre en
congé du ps pour protester contre
l'attitude de leur direction à l'égard
de l'usiné sidérurgique unis métal de
trith-saint-léger
et puis le futur avion de combat
européen a peut-être du plomb dans l
aile
en effet les directeurs des armements
des cinq pays concernés viennent de se
séparer sur un constat de divergence
la france et l'espagne refuse de signer
l'accord intervenu entre l'italie la
grande-bretagne et la république
fédérale allemande
cette dernière ayant semble-t-il changé
de camp thème de la discorde les besoins
différents des partenaires mais au delà
il ya bien sûr la vive concurrence des
firmes d'assaut et british aerospace
pour un marché potentiel de 1000
appareils
un pactole de 30 milliards de dollars
véronique bonnet laurent quel avion de
combat succédera en 95 mirage 2000
jaguar et tornado
jusqu'à présent il y avait au moins un
élément d'accord entre les cinq pays
européens concernés le poids de l'avion
fixé à 9 tonnes 5
depuis hier il semblerait qu'une fois
même plus le cas d'un côté il ya les
allemands les italiens les anglais dont
les directeurs de l'armement viennent
d'opter à turin pour cet avion
l'aea de la british aerospace un avion
lourd et puissant ayant à long rayon
d'action
de l'autre côté les espagnols et les
français partisans d'un avion plus léger
et donc moins cher
inspiré du prototype rafale de dassault
un avion capable d'assumer des missions
d'appui au sol et d'équipés l'aéronavale
face à la détermination des premiers qui
viennent de lancer l'étude du projet qui
défendent la france et l'espagne n'ont
que deux semaines pour réagir et donner
leur réponse définitive
cette décision se prendra au plus haut
niveau car c'est une décision politique
avant tout d'autant que la volonté
d'aboutir unis dans le secteur
aéronautique est le seul moyen pour
l'europe de faire face aux grandes
compétitions de l'avenir
les assassinats racistes continu en
afrique du sud
hier c'est une avocate noir de durban
opposé à l'apartheid qui a été tué par
un commando de quatre hommes madame
médecins gays avaient pris la relève de
son mari lui même militant de là il
s'est lui aussi abattu par des inconnus
il ya trois ans par ailleurs la france
vient de décider d'apporter de nouvelles
aides au noir d'afrique du sud
le ministère de la coopération annoncé
ce soir le déblocage de fonds pour les
familles des détenus afin de financer le
projet de clinique de l'épousé de nelson
mandela et pour aider la première
université noirs libres à johannesburg
et au cap
cet été le festival ce n'était pas
seulement avignon aix montpellier où
charles à c'était aussi alger où seize
ans après le festival panafricain on a
renoué en quelque sorte les fils de la
jeunesse et de la musique
l'afrique noire était là la musique
nationale aussi et si vous ajoutez à
tout cela une pincée de groupes beurre
banlieue vous avez le cocktail d'alger
un cocktail qui nous est offert ce soir
par hubert coudurier
13 millions d'algériens sont nés après
l'indépendance de tir de la population
ont surgi en pleine édification de la
révolution socialiste et oubliés par les
contraintes de la croissance économique
partagée entre les traditions islamiques
et les influences occidentales mais
surtout très non leur ennui dans les
rues depuis 1969 du festival panafricain
et ne s'était presque rien passé à alger
cette fois le gouvernement a mobilisé
des moyens importants les problèmes
matériels logement notamment étant moins
critique la pression culturelle des
générations montant ne peut plus être
négligé
je pense qu'il ya eu une musique
traditionnelle qui a petit à petit
évolué et qui a eu des groupes des
groupes pop arabe
il ya une grande mode à l'est dans les
années soixante dix où c'était de bon
ton de chante en arabe sur du pop genre
cas steven neil young et tout ça et
petit à petit ça évolue et là on a vu
naître un groupe s'appelle t 34 qui est
le premier rock algérien pure souche
donc ça prouve que les choses avancent
la chanson qui m'a permis d'être devant
vous ce soir banlieue
il regarde sa ville devant qu'il a il
attend monts et celle qui lui fragile
difficile et pourtant en pointe karim
kassem vous sentez très différents oui
votre musique c'est quoi exactement
pareils par rapport au rock
elle se nourrit de quoi ça mélange de
tout en fait ce bâtiment que nous et
fluence un rail
j'habite musique andalouse même du rock
du funk qui fait le rythm n blues c'est
un peu tout ça c'est que tout ce qu'on
écoute tout ce qu'on aime
là comme ailleurs la musique n'a pas de
frontières l'avenir dira toutefois une
impulsion donnée par ce festival est
significative si au lieu d'être un
épiphénomène
il traduit une véritable évolution des
moeurs et puis sport maintenant puisque
ce soir avait lieu la cinquième soirée
le championnat de france de football
une rencontre attendue celle de bordeaux
contre nancy attendu car le champion
sortant avait fait mardi son premier
faux pas devant le paris saint germain
au parc des princes une défaillance
passagère ou pas telle est la question
posée à daniel lauclair
c'était bien sûr le match du rachat pour
bordeaux les girondins de bordeaux en
maillots bleus ont dû attendre la
deuxième période pour obtenir gain de
cause face à une équipe de nancy très
prudente est très bonne sur le plan
défensif et le but libérateur arrive à
la 59e minute sur une superbe tête de
trouver renders le joueur envoie
stalmans nouvelles recrues a bordeaux on
en restera d'ailleurs là malheureusement
cette victoire a été un petit peu ternie
par la blessure de jean tigana
toujours est il que bordeaux encaissé
l'essentiel à savoir les deux points de
la victoire
alors je vous dirais qu'il n'ya plus de
que deux équipes invaincues dans le
championnat de france de première
division
le paris saint germain et nantes qui ont
réalisé un match nul ce soir fait
marquant de la soirée on a inscrit 30
buts c'est le record depuis le début de
la compétition
il faut aussi noter les deux victoires à
l'extérieur celle de brest et de niche
vous propose de voir tout ça sur nos
panneaux
le paris saint germain a été stoppé dans
son élan mais obtient toutefois le point
du match nul en mayenne la pénitence est
terminée pour bastia qui a retrouvé son
stade de furiani est également le chemin
de la victoire en battant toulon 2 à 1
beaucoup de buts sur la canebière 3 à 3
entre marseille et lens dans le duel à
l'européenne pas de vainqueur entre metz
et nantes bordeaux a battu nancy nous
l'avons vu un à zéro
brest c'est la surprise de la soirée
brest qui a réussi l'exploit revenant
battre sur le stade de l'abbé deschamps
auxerre 2 buts à 1
lille a dominé sochaux 2 1 après trois
défaites toulouse s'est bien repris en
battant rennes
4 1 monaco 2-0 face à strasbourg et dans
le match des promus c'est nice qui a
remporté son premier succès de la saison
en battant le havre sur sa pelouse 2
juin ce qui nous donne au classement 1er
paris saint-germain seul en tête avec 9
points 2e bordeaux qui revient dans la
course en tête avec 8 points 3e on
trouve un trio de trois équipes
composées de lens toulon nantes avec 7
points et dans le bas du tableau ça va
déjà mal pour deux équipes sudistes
marseille et bastia qui occupent les
deux dernières places du classement il
faut noter que la prochaine journée du
championnat aura lieu le vendredi 9 août
une question encore daniel veut jouer
aux courses
oui de temps en temps bien regardé avec
intérêt les pronostics de monsieur
courtine pour le tiercé qui se court à
deauville le prix de honfleur avec 21
partants ou plutôt départementaux en 10
11 fox au à 13,16 de joker à ne pas
oublier de monsieur courtine le 8
las le 16 le 19 et le 6 le 19 un joli
non et puis attention pour les
vacanciers qui souhaiterait de gagner
demain matin leur lieu de villégiature
comme vous le voyez sur cette
diapositive pour la région ile de france
il serait du plus mauvais goût de
prendre la route entre minuit et midi à
moins évidemment d'aimer la promiscuité
le temps maintenant le grand beau temps
n'est pas pour demain
la majeure partie du pays sera traversé
par des passages pluvieux se tuer le
matin de la bretagne à la picardie si
les choses iront en s'améliorant dans
l'après midi
l'orage menace racan mal quant aux
températures et bien elle se
ressentiront cette situation elles
seront plus faibles que la moyenne
saisonnière de 18 à 25 degrés sur le
nord de 26 à 30 degrés sur la moitié sud
du pays
le prochain rendez vous avec soir 3 aura
lieu demain à 21h35 pour une édition qui
vous sera présenté par richard tripot
attendant je vous souhaite le bon soir
et vous rappelle l'essentiel de
l'actualité
le feu a repris dans le sud est
le débat sur les responsabilités lui
comment ce recentrage à l'auvergnate un
conseiller municipal de clermont ferrand
change de camp
l'avion européen bas de laine la france
et l'espagne font bande à part
à
normalement